now the New Labour leader circus stahma
has promised to engage constructively
with the government as it tackles
coronavirus but he still has some
criticisms of their approach and is
today calling for some urgent talks to
ensure Parliament returns as planned
from its Easter break and secare joins
us now from North London thank you for
being with us today
I just want to start off looking on the
death rates that we've seen from
coronavirus on Friday the UK reported
980 people dying in hospital after
testing positive for covert 19 yesterday
the figure was 917 I mean that's a
higher daily total than any we've seen
posted in Spain or Italy we just heard
from Alec Shama they're saying the
government took the right steps at the
right time do you think they did well I
think those figures are really alarming
they are high and we need to remember
that behind every figure is a family
shaken to its foundation because it's
lost a family member and it can't even
carry out the most poignant of
ceremonies a funeral in a way that they
like so they are alarming what we all
want the whole country wants the Labour
Party wants the government wants is to
see that figure flattened and hopefully
start going down the figure-4 hospital
admissions the tragic death figures we
want to see them going down and whatever
measures are necessary now for the
government to take whether that's
increasing capacity in the NHS or
whether that's lock down to get those
figures down we will support it of
course there will be questions in due
course about what happened when but the
most important thing is we do have that
unity of purpose which is to try to get
those figures down and we will support
the government in that we will ask
challenging questions difficult
questions about where we go next about
what's happened in the past but I think
the whole nation desperately wants those
figures to go down every day we see the
figures we shudder at the thought of the
families that are affected by it
we saw the what had happened in Italy at
a time when 200 people were dying in
Italy tens of thousand people were going
to the Cheltenham Festival to watch
horse racing with the government too
slow to act
well there are going to be difficult
questions about whether the government
was too slow but now is not the time for
those but the national effort has to be
about reducing those numbers and as I
say that's increasing the capacity of
the NHS it's about social distancing and
following the government's guidance that
is what we all have to be focused on but
there is then the critical question and
it is about planning the what like the
issue you raised which is what happens
next because we know pretty well that a
vaccine won't be ready for 12 months or
so if the figures start to go down what
will happen in the next 12 months and
that's why I've asked for Parliament to
be recalled that's why I've asked for
the government to tell us what the exit
strategy is because we need to know in
that 12 months and what is going to
happen there are various possibilities
but the government needs to set out its
exit strategy because it needs to plan
for those 12 months it needs to do that
planning now it needs to be open about
it that's why it's so important the
Parliament is sitting okay let's take
both of those points in turn fastly on
Parliament being recalled it's pretty
clear that you want Parliament to come
back after the Easter recess and I'm
sure that many things could be done
remotely but at the same time when those
death toll figures are so high
surely the priority should be slowing
the spread of the virus you're not
worried that recalling Parliament might
risk that well it's very important in a
crisis like this that Parliament is
sitting so that decisions can be
properly scrutinized so that the
concerns of constituents can be put to
relevant ministers now and that's why
I'm saying Parliament must be recalled
as soon as possible how we're recalled
and how we say it is obviously a
question we're going to have to discuss
because physically it's impossible to
see how we can sit in the usual way
we're going to have to think about
working differently in New Zealand
they've said I pay special select
committee to look at coronavirus it's
chaired by the leader of the Opposition
and it operates on a daily basis using
technology so people can see Parliament
at work that may be one possibility but
that's why today I've asked for urgent
talks to come up with an arrangement for
Parliament to sit so MPs can
I just want to interrupt you guys I just
want to interrupt you here because I am
getting a notification now that a
spokesperson for the lead to the house
Jacob Riis morgue has confirmed that
Parliament will return on the 21st of
April so that's something I'm guessing
that you must welcome well I'm pleased
about that I what still want to have the
urgent talks because it's got to sit
effectively I don't see how it can sit
in the ordinary way and I think the
sooner we can scrutinize decisions the
better you've seen just this weekend a
real issue about protective equipment
with the government saying one thing and
the frontline saying another now I don't
doubt that the government is doing
everything it can to get the protective
equipment to the people that need it as
quickly as possible and I don't pretend
it's not a very difficult thing to do
but there is a mismatch Matt Hancock the
health secretary said on Friday that
there was enough equipment the frontline
says otherwise the the Medical
Association did a survey last week
doctors on the frontline in high-risk
areas are saying 50% of them are saying
they haven't got the equipment they need
Kingston hospital yesterday said they're
running out of gowns so this is a
difficult exercise I understand the
government's trying to rise to the
challenge here but there's a mismatch
and that's the sort of thing that
Parliament needs to pursue through
individual MPs putting the points to
ministers we need accountability in this
talking about the role of a personal
protective equipment something that
clearly many people feel very strongly
about we've all heard difficult stories
of people on the front line and the
Royal College of Nursing has issued
guidance to say that if nurses feel they
haven't got that protective equipment
that they need masks goggles gowns
then they should effectively refuse to
treat people with coronavirus is that
the right thing to do well they're in a
position to give guidance to those in
their association and they should give
that guidance the most important thing
is that that protective equipment is
there and that's why we're pushing the
government on this this is the sort of
opposition I said that we would put
forward constructive I want the
government to get this right I want to
support the government to get this right
but we need
to point out the difference between what
they're saying and the position on the
front line so that it can be fixed
nobody wants anybody to be put in this
position key workers on the front line
are taking risks and they're entitled to
the protection that they need through
the equipment so I challenged the
government hard on this not just to
score a point but actually to say what
can we do to put this right if there's a
problem let's fix it let's identify what
the cause of the concern is and let's
fix it a parliament of course can play a
part in this because individual MPs have
had lots and lots of examples of what's
going on in their patch in their
constituency bringing that together
allows the government to see where the
problem is so it can fix it yesterday
Priti Patel asked about protective
equipment said I'm sorry if people feel
there had been failings and I asked Alec
Sharma just a few moments ago if he
would apologize further fails to get
Matt to the front line and he didn't do
so should the government be apologising
to frontline workers I think it would be
smart of the government to acknowledge
that their ambition for the equipment to
be where it should be in the right
quantity at the right time isn't being
matched and probably just to apologize
for that and get on with it
but I think the whole nation wants this
fixed and wants to move forward so I'm
trying to resist calls for apologies or
or criticizing past decisions what we
need is what's the problem where are the
real issues and what can we do to fix it
and as I said last week when I became
leader of the Labour Party I will work
with the government on this we will
support them in trying to get this right
we point out the problem in order that
it can be fixed ok so what does that
mean saying that you want to work
constructively with the government does
that simply mean that you're not going
to try and score party political points
you'll go to the odd briefing or does
that actually mean that you're prepared
to join a government of national unity
or do something actually radical and
different it's that we will be
constructive and so what I've said is
this we will work with the government I
spoke to the Prime Minister last
Saturday about this I said we will work
with you we will have the courage to
support you where that's the right thing
to do increasing capacity
yes having the restrictions the lockdown
we support you in that because we know
what you're trying to achieve and we
will say so and that's why I've said
repeatedly follow government advice we
support the government on this but we
also will ask the difficult searching
questions where we think they've been
mistakes or things haven't happened
quickly enough but the purpose and this
is the important bit the purpose of that
challenge is not to score party
political points it's not opposition for
the sake of opposition it's to identify
those mistakes identify when the
government's going too slowly so that
something can be done about it through a
constructive criticism and working with
the government where we can do so I want
to ask you about the exit strategy
because this is what lots of people will
be looking at the forward planning the
the strategy going forward because many
people will be thinking look it's easy
to criticize the government for not
being straight about having an exit
strategy it's easy to do what you're
doing which is to say the pub government
needs to lay out what the exit strategy
should be the difficulty is that many of
the things that people hoped would give
us a way out of the crisis is simply a
very very long way off
the antibody tests are not good enough a
vaccine is going to be months away at
best you don't have a magic solution
either do you
Sophie vite the position is this we we
want the number of admissions to
hospital and the and the tragic deaths
go down to flatten and go down and I
desperately hope that's going to happen
the whole nation wants that to happen so
that's where we are now we all know that
a vaccine which is the sort of end exit
strategy is probably 12 months away so
the question is what happens in that
intervening 12 months now I'm pushing
the government on this because we need
to plan for it we can't just arrive at
it without a plan there are a number of
possibilities you could have mass
community testing and tracing that is
one possibility you could have shielding
of the very vulnerable you could have
the the social distancing being turned
on or off if you like
these could be used together but which
of it is it and the reason this matters
is because firstly we need to have the
trust of the public that they know
what's going to happen in these 12
months people are really frightened
frightened for their health frightened
for the economy so they need to know but
also we need to plan if the plan is mass
community testing and then tracing that
tells us we need to ramp up testing far
beyond what the government's already
promised if that's the right route so
I'm pushing the government on this
because I think what I don't want to
happen is in a number of weeks we arrive
at the situation and we haven't got a
clear plan okay and I am now coronavirus
of course feels all-consuming at the
minute but this is my first interview
with you since you became the leader at
the Labour Party and I am quite keen to
reflect a little bit on where you plan
to take the party at this time of
national emergency now in your
acceptance speech you talked about
reconnecting with the country and you
said where that requires change we will
change where that requires to rethink we
will rethink so what's where
specifically will labour change under
your leadership well I think the first
thing we need to do is to acknowledge
the scale of the task that we face we
lost in December
very badly it was a devastating loss and
there was no good that came out of that
loss but we didn't just lose the last
ever election we lost four in a row so
of course things need to change so
wearing my first task is my first task
is to unite our party it's the oldest
saying in politics that divided parties
don't win elections and that's because
it's true so we've got to unite our
party I was very pleased to be able to
win the leadership last week and now I
need to bring the party together to it
to be an effective opposition so that's
the first task we then need to be
unrelentingly focused on the next
general election I just want to come I
just want to come in if I may I just
want to come in if I may yeah because
you say you want to change the party and
you say that there's a huge challenge so
far you've just said that you want to
unite the party and you want to focus on
the next election I mean that's obvious
isn't it what what's the big idea
what are you actually going to do to
change well the first thing I did was to
be absolutely clear about things like
anti-semitism and that's why i issued an
apology in my acceptance speech the
first opportunity that I had to our
Jewish communities and that's why I've
already had meetings with Jewish leaders
in the past week so absolutely
demonstrating change I then put together
a very talented diverse shadow cabinet
from across the whole of United Kingdom
to demonstrate that we've got the
strength and talent in depth across the
labour party to take us forward
obviously where we go next is now framed
by coronavirus because the arguments
about our economy are going to be
different and the argue and the
arguments about how we value people
frankly are going to be different we
can't go out every Thursday on our
doorsteps and clap for our key workers
who are keeping us going in this period
and then at the end of this return to
business as usual so the job of the
Labour Party is to spell out that vision
of a better society when we're through
coronavirus but ok well let's talk a bit
about that vision because you're right
of course to say that all of the old
certainties are going to be ripped up
because of coronavirus and there's going
to be a crippling economic cost as well
you've said that you can't have another
decade of austerity but there will be
austerity won't there of some form
that's the reality because we'll be
paying us off for a generation what
there are choices about how you deal
with debt and deficit and the government
this government going back to 2010 for
the last decade has chosen austerity
that is that has caused great harm to
many communities and many individuals
across the United Kingdom what we can't
have is another decade of austerity on
top of this decade of austerity just
look what it's done to the health
service our public services social care
all of these areas for 10 years what
would you do instead then would you
raise taxes rather than cuts down
spending
well we we may well have to raise taxes
of course but you're asking me a
question that nobody can realistically
answer because we don't yet know what
the damage the economy is going to be we
do know it's going to be damaged we can
see that already we don't know because
we don't know how long this is going to
go on quite what the damage will be so
pretending now that I can tell you what
will be needed in 2024 is not something
that I'm going to do but it is clear
that we're going to have to take a
different approach lots of people who
are key workers today going in today as
they've been going in every day have
been underpaid and undervalued for years
that cannot go on there's got to be a
fundamental difference going forward
okay now you completed your shadow
cabinet reshuffle last week and you
booted out quite a lot of jeremy
corbyn's old allies which a burger and
dom butler john tricky in Lavery john
macdonald Diane Abbott have left the
stage I got the sense when I last
interviewed Jeremy Corbyn that he was
angling for a job in the shadow cabinet
that wasn't forthcoming either is this
the end of Corbin ISM well I've never
accepted these labels based on an
individual what I'm trying to do is
build a team a diverse team from
different parts of the party across the
country that can take us on the journey
from here to where we need to be at the
next general election and what I said in
my election campaign and what I say to
my top team now is don't look to the
Past for people to cling to we've got to
do the thinking here we've got to build
the policy build and the project build
and and the strategy to take us into the
next general election so that the the
duty and responsibility is on us now to
do what's necessary over the next four
years not not to to look backward to
other individuals whoever they may be a
key part of the Jeremy Corbyn project as
well was the campaign group momentum who
really backed his leadership to the hilt
when you were elected they tweeted to
say in this new era momentum will play a
new role will hold Kier to account and
make sure he keeps his promises and on
the show last week Anne
Allen Johnson referenced that tweet and
said to me I'm afraid there's no sign
they'd borrowed the weapons and have
dedicated themselves to unity and as a
result labor under your leadership needs
to purge ourselves of the far-left
insurgents of momentum is he right
look what I've said to our membership is
this whether you voted for me or not I
will represent you I will listen to you
and I'll bring our party together I want
to hear all the voices in the Labor
Party of course I should be held to
account for what I've said and what I do
of course I should that's absolutely
right but what I want to do is to unify
our party we've got five hundred and
eighty thousand members that's the
biggest political party in Europe we
need to pull that together as a really
strong fighting force so I will talk to
everybody within our party about how we
do that okay and just finally I'm
running out of time I'm quite interested
to find a bit more about yourself that
new leader the Labour Party blank canvas
big mandate to do what you want
now you went from Grammar School to
Oxford you then became Director of
Public Prosecutions head of the CPS
electors as an MP in 2015 five years
later you're leading the Labour Party's
a very impressive CV it's also quite an
establishment CCB though do you think
some people may feel it's time for an
insurgent well along the way I've been a
human rights lawyer fighting cases
across the world against governments and
the establishment as you put it so I
don't buy into this you're either the
establishment or you're not well I
focused on is what needs to get done and
how do I get it done but I've spent many
many years fighting the establishment as
you put it whether that's for trade
unionists or that's people on but on
death row across the world you name it
I've been there fighting on the front
line with them of course I've also
worked in the Crown Prosecution Service
I also work with the police service in
Northern Ireland on some of implementing
some of the Good Friday proposals and
what I focused on is not am I the
establishment or not the establishment
what's the job that needs to be done
what's the the wrong that needs to be
right
and that's the focus I will take leading
the Labour Party which is how do we get
the Labour Party a most incredible force
for good from where it is now into a
position where we can serve our country
again in government okay
thank you very much on the program this
morning kissed on about a new leader of
Labour Party